[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
qu'ovide 19 le sénat sonne la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
députés et sénateurs réunis jeudi 21
juillet 2022 en commission mixte
paritaire ont abouti à un accord sur le
projet de loi sanitaire
le sénat a marqué le texte de tout son
empreinte
l'accord auquel est parvenue la
commission mixte paritaire reprend ainsi
les apports du sénat adopté sur
proposition du rapporteur philippe bas
premièrement l'abrogation complète des
dispositifs exceptionnels de lutte
contre la copie de 19 que sont le régime
d'état d'urgence sanitaire et le régime
de gestion de la crise sanitaire
concrètement cela signifie qu'il ne sera
plus possible pour le gouvernement de
réactiver un pass sanitaires ou
vaccinale ou encore de confiner la
population
deuxièmement l'instauration d'un
mécanisme de protection sanitaire aux
frontières
si un nouveau variant très dangereux
apparaît un test pourrait alors être
exigés pour l'accès au territoire
troisièmement l'institution d'une
procédure permettant la réintégration
des personnels non vaccinés au contact
de personnes fragiles dès que la haute
autorité de santé que le parlement
pourra saisir aura constaté que
l'obligation vaccinale ne sera plus
médicalement justifiés
le texte de compromis sera examiné par
le sénat en séance publique le 26
juillet 2022
pour en savoir plus consultez le biais
d'actualité sur le site du sénat
[Musique]